Congress is facing a Friday night
deadline on its 1.3 trillion dollar
spending package and already the house
has bumped back and expected both until
Thursday it's going to extend our week
into the weekend perhaps what this just
shows why this is a really a terrible
way to have to do business where the
final decisions are left up to four
people that's a reference to the big
four leaders of Congress McConnell
Schumer Ryan and Pelosi and both Senate
leaders expressed optimism they'll be
able to pass this bill the text of the
legislation was supposed to be released
last night to set the stage for a house
boat on Wednesday we got close but we
just we weren't gonna let you know
midnight stopped us from finishing our
job of negotiating it up among the final
issues cost-sharing reductions for
Obamacare which Democrats have wanted
and the ongoing struggle over addressing
the so-called dreamers in exchange for
border wall funding but top Democrat
said both sides are far apart on daca
and border security we're going to keep
fighting and trying the courts have
given something of a reprieve but there
are going to be lots of opportunities
for us to try and help the doctor kids
another concern the risk of a government
shutdown this week due to mother
nature's inclement weather but so far
the Senate Majority Leader doesn't
appear to be worried what my focus is on
is finishing this omnibus appropriation
which will fund the government through
September the 30th and we're going to do
it this week there's also pressure on
the Republican side to get out of town
before a major gun protest comes here
perhaps some deadlines motivation